good morning Millennials welcome back to
LA week toasts LA we are back with our
second episode of the week it is
Wednesday we are hope you are having a
bright sunny beautiful happy day we are
sweating our asses off here in LA
working extra hard this is our third
podcast of the day third party s podcast
of the day I think we might be all
talked out but we'll see how it goes we
always have something else to say but I
don't know today has been a long one it
has been a long one but we are chugging
along because we are gonna be graced by
Tania rad who I'm very excited for she's
a modern woman hosted the scrubbing in
podcast host of on Air with Ryan
Seacrest she's just like a very
well-connected woman and also a toaster
and I have so many questions for her let
me Jason Elle professional the toasters
have so many questions like it's just
gonna be truly Q&A it's gonna also be
just like I feel like it's gonna be a
panel just like modern what yeah modern
women like being modern yeah and female
modernization right maternity it's the
modernity you have Tania rad I wish
today's episode was brought to you by
modern fertility because I wish we don't
have a read for them this week but that
would've been really great that would
have been really great but you know what
else has been really great our past 24
hours since we sat here on this show I
have been a whirlwind and I feel as
though we need to recover the toasters
just so that for ourselves we can digest
like today was insane but last night was
even crazier after we wrapped
yesterday's episode we went straight to
Dancing with the Stars they told us to
get there at 3:45 because they started
at 5 o'clock we got there at 4:55 and I
was 100% certain they weren't gonna let
us in because the email was very
threatening like arrived on time right
but they let us in because you know they
had to and we looked so the part because
the invitation said look glamorous and
so we changed into our like feather boas
an old hollywood show I wore a sparkly
blouse and it was incredible you
probably saw us on TV Lauren's friends
and family maybe you're watching today
because you saw us on TV you're like
were those girls new friends like they
were so cool and skinny and beautiful we
sat right behind christie brinkley who
is just an absolute treasure witch
yeah she is and also who else was Erica
Ramos friends and family were around us
they were really sweet Lindsay L the
country star was a part of Lauren's
friends and family - it was really Kevin
from the office was there because Kate
Flannery was on the office I saw in page
six today that the people who play james
Van Der Beek's parents on Dawson's Creek
were there also the new stars of the new
high school musical the series they were
there too it was really just like cool
Erin answer
obviously we saw Carrie Ann Inaba Carrie
Ann Inaba fell off her chair and it was
Nats ergo the snatcher got a mic today
the snatcher has her voice back that's
when I was really like holy [ __ ] this is
live TV cuz like I was like oh they're
gonna cut that like we're gonna have
noticed yeah I think that was real
yeah oh I thought of Heron delayed no
apparently it's happened before because
they used rolling chairs and they have a
very small platform and so um Todd
what's the host name um
Tom was like oh wait there's something
on the floor and she got like freaked
out like what is it and she has no room
she stood up for a second and then went
to find her chair again but because she
was in a rolly chair it wasn't there
when she sat back down instead and I
thought for a second like oh they'll cut
that out but then I realized it's live
television yeah
oh I guess it probably looks cool or on
television much like a lot of the show
yes the show it was really rasli and
dazzly I was a lot of work to be an
audience member oh my god they will be
you have to stand every two seconds we
had the clap right and so you know how
in reward shows like it's recently gone
viral you know how an award shows its
whistling gone viral
um with a celebrity's fake clapping came
in people like Nicole Kidman doesn't
really clap like that it's like no they
make you stand up and clap so much you
get tired so you start your fake clap I
was like this on your hands the clap and
it's like some of the performers like
the audience members have props so
forlorn elena's we had like little
lights for the high school musical and
we had like little flags and we had to
rehearse the flags like we know how to
wave a flag okay they had us clapping
I'm it started I was sitting next to her
ahmo's grade school friend's mom and her
and I our arms were killing no I'm like
she was older and like she really she
had way more like zealous I said to
myself I was like I'm not clapping
anymore and she was like right it was
really really painful but it was still
really cool to be there it was very glam
we're gonna love being on like the CBS
lot it was all really cool it was really
cool it was so TV and it's like exactly
what you think it was and I think
sometimes when you see something in real
life it is a light town but this was so
not a letdown it is so glamorous the
dancing was fabulous the stars were
fabulous nobody
at home which was weird yeah but you
know what at least like we only had good
vibes no I was actually really looking
forward to like feeling the awkward vibe
in the room like once the show is over
because once the show is over everyone
pretty much stands on the stage and all
the the audience members leave but if
your friends and family you can stand
and like stand on the dance room floor
and like I was like wanted to be there
with like whoever was going home you
know yeah yeah that would have been I
guess kind of cool as our resident
Dancing with the Stars stand yeah the
snatcher what you think stands dancing
with the snitch what do you think of the
experience I thought it was great I mean
I it was awesome glitz and glam
glamorous but like it's so better to
watch on TV like the props were so big
that you couldn't even see the dancing I
was like that time he went to the Super
Bowl yeah that was awful Justin
Timberlake like he was his back was
towards us the whole time and he wasn't
even wearing a microphone yeah but I do
have to say it was super impressive like
the way that they were able to like set
up the dance floor and then like take
you down in literally minutes Betty was
all of the every right we got a lot of
questions about the confetti because
pretty much every single person's dance
ends in confetti and by the next
commercial break like it's totally
cleaned up and what I noticed was that
more often than not the confetti that
they threw out was streamers not little
pieces of confetti so then it makes it a
lot easier to pick up the streamers I
saw people like grabbing a bunch of
streamers and then literally just
pulling like a rope because it gets so
much more off the ground so that was
like a little interesting like TV trick
that I learned yeah it was something
that I noticed that I would never have
seen on TV he's like the pros are fully
telling the stars the next dance yeah
like you see them like screaming what
the next one is it's like hmm yeah
interesting I mean it's hard to remember
obviously and like they don't they're
not pros there and as our resident
future dancer like did you feel more
excited did it make you more nervous
like don't actually be on the show I
felt more certain than ever that like
that's where I need to be that that is
my life school and I think it I know
it's like I could probably dream like a
little bigger but I think it's a great
honest goal and it's a great platform to
also we have to tell you guys that when
we were walking in we ran into the sky
and we just thought he'd like worked on
the lot but he ended up being I'm Allie
Brooks manager and he was really he s he
heard the podcast cuz everyone the world
listens to the Swap cast and he was like
thank you for trying to serve justice
for Allie scores
yeah and last night that we got the
justice person to get ready points but
it's like yeah you heard what we said
about justice Bradley Brooke and then
did you catch the next week when we were
first cyberbullying yeah but it's we
know it was just a less
like everybody like the morning toast
reaches everyone they might not listen
every day but when it is pertinent to
the situation it will reach him and it
makes you think twice before you seek
but then it also realizes like this
platform up for it too so many
opportunities including one in which we
need today because after Dancing with
the Stars
we went out to dinner and we went to the
friend it was important you guys please
listen we were eggs which is ESA we were
being thirsty we were all just upward
like we want to go to the most best
restaurant so we went to Craig's its
Hollywood and there's always paparazzi
outside Craig's and we you know we
watched out of the car like probably the
odds of someone ever taking a picture of
us are actually like one in a thousand
probably but you never know and you just
don't want to be caught off guard so we
pull up there's a million paparazzi
outside we get out of the car looking
glamorous things so coy yeah they look
up and then look back down like they
wanted nothing to do with us we walked
in whatever I mean a very low-key
low-key dinner just really wanted to
fuel up the food Oh Craig's is so good
yeah we saw like a couple celebs some
real stars there so it wasn't even
offensive that they didn't want to take
Jerry King at best they'd confuse us
with someone like think Margo was Emma
Chamberlain who she looks more and more
like every single day totally okay so we
didn't get paparazzi and then on our way
out our cars outside we walked to the
door and all of a sudden I'm being
flashed like it's nobody's [ __ ]
business like flash absolutely flash
flash flash and I didn't even have time
to process what was going on until I
crack a smile and I get in the car and
we're all just like what the [ __ ] just
happened like all three of us like my
shirt was unbuttoned Margo's hair was in
a bun and I don't even know what Jackie
nightma gut was out like because we
didn't get paparazzi on the way in we're
like there's no way out walked out like
separately like I walked first Claudia
walk second mark work third and they
snapped our whole procession and like
honestly I was smiling like I was trying
to be so coy I literally almost put up I
was so excited and I wanted them to know
like I had my picture taken before and
it's usually like one snap maybe two or
three this was flash flash flash flash
multiple cameras multiple people
multiple shots I can understand how
someone could get hooked on the fame
honestly it was it was sound is is a
dict invigorate like I was hearing in my
sleep all night I'm like I wanted it
back it's like I was I was high on
heroin and then he'd get back there yeah
that's how subs feel people get addicted
to the fame and I never really
understood like I've I've gone I've
really thought a lot about how like I've
been in quote places and met coke
I never lose channel like people really
get so carried away I'm like loot like
really lose control with Fame and then
after hearing those sounds I totally
understand it it's the paps man yeah
anyways what we need you for is we
aren't able to find the pictures
probably because nobody knew who we were
and they probably took our pictures by
accident like thinking we were you know
probably thought I was Ricki Lake or
something and they probably then like
through the memory card in the trash
yeah but we need those pictures so like
if you are we need the TI a on this if
you're like a sleuth or if you work in
publishing you have access to these
sorts of just look please dado database
yeah he was wearing a pink feather top
you can't miss her you really couldn't
miss me it looks like a [ __ ] round
disco ball being sparkly shirt with big
sleeves and Morgan was ready like a
sleek black and white jumpsuit with her
hair like in a very messy bun so just
please like please help us please look
for the photos we have some people on
the job and it's not looking good which
makes me feel as though we're gonna have
to call the paparazzi before we leave
this yeah well what we keep asking
people who live here we're like how do
we call the paparazzi I'm addicted I'm
addicted and you know what I'm not above
calling them paparazzi and I'm not even
above paying for my own nose it sucked
at it and it really launched him and
Heidi into like super stardom for a long
period of time right and also like
influencers pay photographers to do like
shoots of them on the beach like being
cheesy all the time like why can't I pay
paparazzi to take pictures of me outside
a bump in restroom yeah we're going to a
bump in restaurant tomorrow that is
known to have paparazzi outside as well
and if I don't get my picture taken like
I'm just gonna feel so let down because
now having known what it's like I can't
ever walk into a restaurant and like not
have my picture taken I'm literally
gonna need Ben to be there with like an
iPhone yeah no I agree we're gonna work
on it um stay tuned but please keep your
eye out if you have these sorts of
credentials yeah and then today we had a
crazy day we did Nick miles podcast this
morning right in early um it was really
fun it was really good conversation kind
of serious um I thought it was such a
productive conversation I so enjoyed I
mean the genesis of the totally vile
relationship knows no bounds and we were
in this this exact room it was really
when the conversation went down he's so
great and it flew by it was a really
long interest it was an hour and a half
I think it might be this teens like
you've never seen us before yeah it was
we never people asked us the same stuff
like how'd you get started like he was
very in-depth and like did obviously did
his research and we talked about stuff
we never really talked like our
relationship yet how we balance it all
here to keep things fresh yeah I thought
it was cool I thought it was cool too I
had a really nice time and then we also
did the lady game which was very
exciting we filled in for Becca Toby
it's why was said she wasn't there but I
do think if it was five people like
we're all so chatty like it would have
been insane so cotton we missed her but
it was better and he was actually just
so interesting we got to do it on the
entertainment tonight lot because that's
where Kelly's office isn't she's like
the sick office and it's just like
really impressed with her whole like
business you know their whole situation
is situated it's aspirational mmm-hmm
and I had a great time it was a whole
episode it was hilarious it's so toasty
it's like I believe that's next week
right next Tuesday yes we'll let you
know when everything's coming out yeah
that'll be exciting for like the
toasters who are also lady hangers and
lady gangers who are also toasters and
then maybe the lady gangers who hate us
yeah and maybe like will hate us more or
move will convert some lady haters it's
exciting yeah it was good stuff and now
we're here we're gonna break down Fast
Five but we're gonna talk to Tanya Brad
and then I'm gonna take the biggest nap
of my life in LA it's like I'm never
here so when I am sick you have to do
absolutely everything you have to do
everything this has been like the
biggest day for us snitch and I also
went to Joan's on third because I
thought about it like going for out I
just like I know that's where some stars
get spotted it's like a it's a lunch
places it's kind of casual it's nothing
too crazy it's not like the Beverly
Hills Hotel and it was not what I
thought it was it's literally like
kitchen cabaret in Great Neck and um
exactly yeah it's one of those places
you have to order and then sit down
which I hate not glamorous whatsoever
we forgot to order our salads chopped
overall had a pleasant experience but we
went really out of our way to go there
and it was unnecessary and you would
have recommend to a friend I know I
would if you would work in the area yeah
but it's not like a staple of LA like to
go out of your way I went to last name
was my first nighttime at Craigs it's a
staple it's a staple first of all the
food is so [ __ ] good it's always a
scene it's always poppin it's like
everyone talked about Craig so when you
get there you expected to be like a
palace you know it's just like a
steakhouse that's so good that like we
were in and out in 30 minutes like the
service like I couldn't lift a finger
without someone putting a clean napkin
underneath it and then the best part is
that we were with my friend who ordered
pigs-in-a-blanket but then we were like
oh no we can't he picks in like it
they're not kosher and the waiter told
us the hotdogs were kosher
so we're phenomenal they were phenomenal
everyone was in tune with what's
necessary and that's just what we like
to see here out in LA so true well I
think without further ado it is time to
deliver the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and it
is for sure but I think everyone needs
to keep in mind that like we're in LA
spending every dollar that we own just
like trying to put on a production and
you know we got to make some coin so
today's episode is brought to you by one
of our favorite sponsors
okay Steve I thank you so much for
sponsoring this episode of toast LA so
the problem with having a phone and
needing a phone case is like you don't
want to drop it and break it but you
don't want to get like a big ugly like
screen protector or like a big ugly
phone that like makes your phone weigh a
thousand pounds of yearning a carpal
tunnel and it's like I thought there was
no way to have like a cute phone that
also won't break but that's not true
because case defy is here to say that it
saved the day their cases have a
two-layer GTECH material construction
and they have passed a drop test from a
height of six and a half feet they offer
military-grade phone protection but the
best part is that they have thousands of
designs to choose from so you'll find
the perfect case for your aesthetic
we both got cases they did a collab with
Lisa Frank which is just so unbranded
like Lisa Frank is everything and the
phone cases are so cute they do tons of
cool collab save tons of you could
personalize the phone case like it's
actually also a great gift
they're great phone cases like you get
your initials on them they're so like
tailored to you I can't recommend highly
now they've done a Saint Laurent collab
they've done a Pokemon Club and Sarah
Jessica Parker collab a Wonder Woman
Club a Rolling Stones Club you're able
to choose your favorite designs colors
and add custom text to create a custom
phone case that no one else will have we
can't imagine going one day without
being without our phones like if my
phone cracks like my heart game over
it's like when my phone sighs I don't
think Nintendo they let you have the
best of both worlds with military-grade
drop protection and a stylish phone case
you'll actually want to show off there's
no need for bulky phone cases that turn
your phone into an ugly brick case defy
cases are sleek and chic as you as your
actual phone they have thousands of
designs for you to choose from and if
celebrities like Kylie Jenner and Gigi
Hadid are obsessed you know this is a
phone case that you can show off on your
Instagram feed 100% go to case defy
dot-com slash toast today to get 20% off
your new favorite phone case that's case
defy calm CAS et ify dot-com / toast for
20% off your phone purchase today from
case to fight calm a / just I love my
case fat case yeah you do I really do
alright let's jump in let's jump right
in because we have a bit of legal news
to tackle today some good some justice
being served actually I guess in all
cases justice is being served because
Felicity Huffman is reporting to prison
to begin her 14-day sentence which is
reported to me that it is October which
keeps shocking me so I just October it's
halfway through October when Gary
Jannetty said his book comes out October
22nd I'm in a murder
a month and then I was like why you
coming to New York next week also can we
talk about Brad and Gary for two seconds
oh yeah we got such positive feedback
from them and it's like everyone knows
Brad and then everyone knows Gary's like
digital personality but Brad I mean Gary
was telling us he doesn't really do like
podcasts a lot like Gary's always on TV
you just that you news red carpet and
I'm really glad that like the toasters
got to see like Gary behind Gary because
they were so cool so fun they have like
such a good relationship I really enjoy
talking I really enjoyed talking to him
they're like great people great guests
so interesting and is good fun I think
they had fun too okay I personally just
like enjoyed listening to them yeah it
was a really good episode I felt really
proud of it same well
Felicity because TV actress Leslie
Huffman is reported to prison Tuesday to
begin serving a 14 day sentence for her
role in the national college admissions
bribery scandal quote Felicity have been
reported today for sentencing to federal
correction institution in Dublin
California our representative for the
actress said in the statement mrs.
Huffman is prepared to serve the term of
imprisonment ordered as one part of the
punishment that the judge imposed on
miss Hoffman's actions
um yes sir she go to prison for 14 days
she's going to a prison that's being
referred to as Club fed it's like they
have like yoga sunbathing yeah it's not
gonna be like a tough 14 days for I feel
like she might want to stay even longer
you know I'm sure being married to
William HMAC you know it's a lot yeah
and like the rumors out there you know
just even the way like this whole
thing's going down yeah like I think
she's the only one who got indicted it's
kind of shading something right like at
least like Massimo and Lori are in it
together yeah like they're their
variables never been they will sink or
they will swim together I just think
this is so crazy and honestly she must
be so relieved that the whole saga is
coming to an end because it's been
months of like her name being dragged
through the press her kids being like
bullying on social media and everyone's
just like really hating on her you know
for obvious reasons so I'm sure like
she's obviously not looking forward to
prison but she's probably really looking
forward to putting this all behind her
yeah and 14a is like not so crazy in a
prison like that well for Lori it's so
different because her um her crime was
committed in Boston right Boston no they
went to USC I know but she keeps going
to oh sorry yeah it's in Boston she's
Margo's right the whole case is in
Boston well Laura was felicity tried in
I don't know but the case operation
varsity blues like was set forth in
Boston so how did Weiss listen
California for Nia I don't know yeah
maybe it's different maybe because they
didn't go to like grand jury or whatever
maybe I have no idea oh yeah right
because Felicity pled guilty and just
like took her punishment but Laurie pled
not guilty so it's being dragged out to
a whole trial yeah which if she does
lose I think will make her sentencing
worse of course because they hate they
hate to wasted your waste like the civil
servant that's time but this is actually
like a swift carriage of justice like
this happened less than a year ago it
was February March when all this barely
has a right to a speedy trial and I
cooperate and in 14 days this will well
plus her her fines and I think she has
some community service to do but this
will all be behind her yeah and she can
get back to work you know right once you
do do your time if anyone wants to work
with her that's the other hill she'll
have two o'clock I don't think it will
be because she's still in shows right
now that she had filmed earlier like
she's she's not irrelevant and by the
teen days from now like clean slate no
yeah I don't know I don't make the calls
you don't read the rules I mean I've
been in this town a few days now I'm
gonna get them pretty close but I still
don't make the calls here in this
industry okay well I look forward to
seeing Felicity Huffman in 14 days yeah
me too like maybe she'll get a tan I
know they've like a sunbathing station
at this prison um she's in great shape
already so maybe it'll be just good for
her mind body soul spirit you know the
whole thing yeah and I mean like the
weight of this she's gonna lose truck
weight like that no but it's really like
the like when you have something on your
mind for so long and it's like taking
over your life whether it's like a life
event or something that you're just
really not looking forward to like when
it's over she's gonna make the biggest
Duty of her life of course yeah like I I
really Judy's are really good um
metaphor for like things in your life do
you know what I mean yeah it's like
poison yeah you know now being released
fretting about painful but it's good to
get it out it is well in a little more
legal news that I did feel the need to
speak on because we you know relate
personally to the matter
Cuba Gooding jr. has been handcuffed for
arraignment and now phases
14 accusers when homegirl the girl who
started all this who was a hero and I
don't know her name and I apologize I
believe she's a Jane Doe
oh really I believe when she uh called
the police she opened the floodgates
like in the best possible way so I think
there was a lot of skepticism in the
very beginning because it was one girl
speaking out and there was a video that
was really blurry and like people are
always so
- like doubt women but now it's like you
can't deny I mean I could never deny
having literally had it happen to me
right um everyone knows it when I was 16
in a club like Cuba Gooding jr. like
walked right by me but his finger at my
button I was like so shocked by it so
this is not shocking at all but good on
everyone for coming forward I mean I
know that he got a range or whatever
because my phone always blows up with um
Google Alerts whenever he's in the news
now my name is like attached to him
which is like like awful like that's
what I'm known for
that's not what you're known for and you
have played a part in helping people
come forward for sure well I just I
don't think this is so great I think
this is so great I want justice to be
served in anyone who's still like on the
fence on this matter which I would never
even think is fabulous separate when
your name was in the news with this I
saw that people like didn't believe you
or thought you wanted money or something
which was insane no I got a number one
part that's underneath the money things
if you like wanted to go out there and
like get someone's money like Cuba
Gooding jr. no I know a little random
snow drugs wasn't that big of a film
that I think like I would probably like
target someone a little wealthier no a
hundred percent maybe like a Murdock or
something you know yeah anyways I hope I
hope justice is served this always
happens that with celebrities like we
get really far like with Kevin Spacey
like we even went to trial and justice
still wasn't served and some could argue
that the court of public opinion is even
more lemming but you know the court of
public opinion hasn't ruled on Cuba
Gooding jr. they have not like it's
something what do we don't know yeah so
I I think this is all good but I won't
be like relieved until homeboy has a
sentence yes until he's found guilty I
agree but we've learned from Kevin
Spacey and so many other people like
that's not always the case like just
because there's tons
I mean OJ just because there's tons of
evidence doesn't mean anything this is
so ironic because he played OJ it is and
like I do hate Cuba Gooding jr. with
every fiber of my being but he was so
good as oh joy he was great I mean that
show was really you couldn't be like a
bad person and a good actor so true
actually you could argue most bad people
are good actors exactly yes okay next
story is one for you because Jennifer
Aniston has made her Instagram debut not
only that but she has joined with a
friend's selfie of the friends um okay
like I know that this story is like
written for me and everyone has been
asking me about it today like all the
podcast we did today in just like
since like all over my Instagram and
like I actually don't give a [ __ ] is
that bad no and you know what that
actually makes sense because you've
never been a Jennifer and a Stan no love
I love that I have not like what's just
interesting to watch her growth like
this morning she had a hundred thousand
followers and now she has four million
oh and Gorna Cox who's been on Instagram
forever and Courtney Cox is very thirsty
on Instagram but she's always a
celebrities she's always posting friends
references she has 4.1 some thinking
Jennifer Aniston is gonna succeed hers
oh my god she's at 4.5 oh oh I'm gonna
check like 30 minutes goes for sure what
it'll be tomorrow when this episode
drops over five could you imagine
getting that many powers in one day
yeah I mean I guess her and Courtney Cox
are both both famous from the same thing
but you probably would argue that
Jennifer Aniston is much more thing yes
and Jennifer Aniston like still does
movies and is out there and Courtney Cox
if she's doing that stuff like I haven't
yeah I haven't come into what was really
interesting about this story and that
what people aren't talking about is the
first picture she posted was with the
six friends which I thought was so cute
because just loved that one and our any
friends missing know that six friends
yes Jackie no I know there's only six
friends but it looks like there's two
people on that picture like I couldn't I
was like I was like Oh where's I don't
know like Phoebe I guess is there yeah I
thought there was more than six friends
no it just looks like very few people it
is so weird but what is so interesting
is that I don't know why I've been made
to think that not all the friends are
friends like I think there was a rumor
for a long time that David Schwimmer was
not really in with the crew mm-hmm and
it's good to see that they're all
hanging out and I didn't really realize
that they all have instagrams and
literally none of them ever posts
because they all had to post for the
friend's 25th anniversary like they did
some sort of like partnership and I
clicked on everyone's instagrams from
the jennifer adding and every single one
of them their most recent picture was
that friend's 24th anniversary from like
a month ago except for Lisa Kudrow okay
yes she's very relevant very active and
she ran into me Mira Sorvino who played
Romy
she ran into her they fold scarves okay
wait she ran into her at a party like a
couple weeks oh and they took a picture
together and she was like you're totally
the Mary oh my and then Mira commented I
beg to differ
like it was so cute and then I went to
Mira's Instagram and she is like oh all
she doesn't talk about Romney Michele
she was taking pictures of all these
Halloween costumes of the blue and pink
dresses from Maria Michelle like I was
just like
that they're leaning into this movie so
much because it's the greatest movie and
I just hate when people hate the thing
that made them famous you know what I
mean I mean your friends really made
Lisa Kudrow famous but like Romy Michele
was still very much yeah we're it part
of her life
yes after ordering I think during maybe
after well I guess Jamison joining
Instagram is like a promotional thing
for the morning show which I'm just
getting increasingly more exciting oh
there's billboards billboards all over
town yeah it's coming in November oh
yeah Margot was just hanging LA it's
just one big billboard okay we're
looking at a landscape right now I see
one two three four five and I can't even
turn six actually it's a good way to
know like what's in theater is what is
on TV like what's code you know that
Jason Momoa has a new show coming out on
Apple TV Taylor and it's very straight
what is it about it is about a land in
the distant future from now where
everyone is blind and there's a blonde
I'm like it sounds like a no we're like
people in my thousands of years from now
everyone is like evolved to the point
where they're blind and then he has a
better and a bit conceit and then the
elders of the community want to kill
Beth okay that sounds kind of good
magical better that sounds good sounds
like Twilight it's given me Twilight
vibes it could be well done yeah cool
trust Jason well let's call the guys
attraction Jason it's quick look this is
a promotion for that film I'm assuming
I'm wondering if she's gonna be active
on it like all the other friends David
Schwimmer has posted twice matt LeBlanc
post like once a year she gives me that
Gwyneth Paltrow vibe yeah oh she like
she does another business or like a
brand that she would promote SmartWater
no maybe now because she's littered the
face of you know SmartWater i love maybe
naturally get even more money from these
sponsors that you worked with her
Instagram post every now and that she
will say wow I can't stop saying 100%
100% usually instead of that I say
totally or you know totally and I guess
I'm evolving towards 100% and I need to
evolve out because I'm not feeling it
what do other people say agreed know
people know people say this right yeah
oh right is horrible
yeah and I only say right when I'm not
listening yeah yeah oh I also say yeah
yeah or no right you know I'm not
listening if I say this that's crazy
oh yeah that's hilarious
it's like ya know you know putting in a
fake laugh is so much effort like that's
actually flattering if you took the time
to fake life for me I appreciate that
I definitely fake laugh before but the
show so naturally finally I don't have
to uh uh oh god I wonder what the
correct thing to say is when you agree
with someone for sure for sure I say a
lot 100% let me know what you think is
the least annoying I'll stick with that
totally totally rocket um just totally
rockin ok ready for our next story
because it's our third or fourth story
it's our fourth story it came here
cruisin through these stories we're
cruising through these stories I think
we just like want to talk about anything
other than the stories because we were
just loving talking about ourselves
today oh it's also like we're in LA
there's so much going on like this is
irrelevant like we're busy being thirsty
we are being quenched by liquid IV like
there's no time to be talking about the
news the food IV is saving my life this
trip and it's the fastest most efficient
way to stay hydrated when you're
traveling and just filming podcasts left
right and center you know time to just
like jug of smart water we're not all
Jennifer Aniston okay um and that's why
I look at that IV is the beverage for us
because if you're trying to drink more
water liquid IV hydrate sweetie hydrates
you two to three times faster and more
efficiently than water alone with an
added bonus in vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and
b12 they have a good bit of give back
mission which is where you can feel good
and do good because like what IV has
donated over 1.5 million sticks to date
to places like Haiti you round out
Puerto Rico and most recently in Nepal
with each purchase you make liquid IV
donates a serving to someone in need all
around the world it's the
fastest-growing wellness brand and you
can find them everywhere even Costco you
can find their hydration multiplier sold
at Costco's nationwide
all of their products use cellular
transplant technologies CT T which is a
specific ratio of glucose would co2
sodium and potassium and when mixed with
water it helps your body absorb more of
the water and nutrients they are
drinking directly into your bloodstream
so basically it comes in little packets
you pour it into your standard beverage
and it like basically it takes the water
that you're drinking and just makes it
like so much better for you yeah and
does better things for your body because
sometimes I like forget to drink water
almost like chug a bottle and then I
know it's not even that it's not enough
like drinking just chug in like that
like it just goes right through my body
and then I have to pee yeah you need the
nutrients you need the electrolytes we
absolutely love liquid IV and we know
you will too right now we're right now
our listeners will get 25% off at liquid
IV calm when you use our code toast at
checkout that's
five percent off anything you order on
liquid IDs website go to liquid IV comm
and enter our promo code toast to get
your savings and start getting better
hydration that's liquid IV com promo
code toast
don't wait start properly hydrating
today liquid I be calm promo code toast
shine on get properly hydrated it's so
important and it will just change your
day let's talk about water it's like
really making me have to pee also I just
drink like a full fountain soda when I
should be drinking my liquid IV and I'm
about to bust okay well you're about to
bust for this next story Margo just
walked in here like looking on
suspicious what's right she looks like
she has like a goodie bag like she just
went trick-or-treating I just want I
just want you to know that Tonya rad
brought me a gift she stopped what did
she bring you a sweet sweet for this
miss you snitch you a snitch I really am
Becca Tilly is here too oh yeah grabbing
in scrubbing in Oh Becca was suppose to
be my oming oh my god Thank You Beverly
for us I'm so excited okay Tori okay try
not to bust because I have a new couple
alert for you that just came out all
away i kneeled and I need everyone's
thoughts I need all hands on deck
because Amanda Stanton has been spotted
with Brendan Fitzpatrick its former rich
kids of Beverly Hills on TMZ has
reported it and you know what they're
sometimes wrong but a lot of the time
and they're right they said the pair was
spotted holding hands at Nobu Newport
Beach over the weekend TMZ has learned a
man and Brendon met through mutual
friends and started seeing each other
about a month ago but like the way that
I think about this story like I believe
that they met on Rio for sure by the way
um and then reality Steve had posted a
picture of someone's feet and like
Amanda's hair reality Steve's like tip
was like oh I was like that's cool but
this is literally not proof these are a
pair of Converse it was just the reality
Steve photo I don't know if I would have
chosen it as a story today because like
that does not a story make TMZ
corroborating the story and placing them
at Nobu Newport Beach it's very specific
I think I'm gonna believe no I
definitely believe and when I heard the
two names together it actually made a
lot of sense um and while I live from
Morgan Stewart and I'm really sad that
her and Brendan couldn't make it work I
really liked Brendan on the show and I
want him to find happiness like I don't
hate him just because I'm totally team
Morgan because I'm like her number one
fan
I'm not sure
so a man is a great girl and I think
this is good they both have like past
histories like you know it's it's hard
when you're divorced or you have kids
like you want to find someone who is
like a similar life experience and
Amanda is divorced so I think that
actually this is a great match yeah it's
not like you loved me if you watch real
rich kids Beverly Hills like you would
definitely like wanted a family and I
think this is like kind of good I think
this is good too and they've been able
to date low-key for a month so they're
past that like newborn phase you know
it's like when we heard about Liam and
Madison Brown going out like we saw them
out on their feet like that's so scary
and that does not bode well because now
they have all this pressure and it can
it can ruin public relationships and I
think it does Demi lavato Mike Johnson
100 anything off his own case 100%
agreed for sure totally
and so I think they're in a good spot
for this to become public news and I
ship I my ship is coming in my ship is
coming in I want happiness for everyone
involved like Morgan Stewart is my idol
queen obsessed with her suicide is her
tomorrow I can't even talk to you about
it and announce it Oh Morgan well by the
time this episode is up tomorrow we will
have already announced it I'm so excited
and I want to play a game with her
because the toasters did a huge post in
the Facebook group who shouldn't or
consumer date max and actually just to
read them off to her and see what she
thinks
a hundred she's the most eligible
Bachelorette in this town and she could
date anyone she wants why you laughing
you see because I said no every time I
say oh I thought you're laughing because
when we started this episode I was like
Jackie I'm so tired I might be able to
talk and I let her have it let you say
one word yeah every single time we're
also filming a behind-the-scenes patreon
video of our trip and you will see how
tired we were before we did this episode
and how she said I have nothing left to
say also I launched presale today for
six new shows a couple in upstate New
York
Ontario Margot helped me Kansas City
finally the Carrie town Tarrytown Verona
New York Englewood New Jersey so if you
weren't able to get tickets to my beacon
show which I know a lot of you weren't
there are now other options in Englewood
Tarrytown which is like I think near
Westchester um tickets available car
with no job calm the presale has started
but because like if you're listening to
this episode you're obviously a good
toaster like you deserve presale the
code is djt one two three all caps and
presale for every I mean artists on sale
goes on sale like on Friday so you can
get tickets or for everyone else girl no
job com code djt one two three you're
wondering why I said Verona so
excitedly but that's the town that Bell
was from from Beauty and the Beast
obviously that was his friend Jersey New
York it's New York she's grown in New
York God no but you know it's probably
named after that that town so it's
deep-rooted in Disney history you told
me that the fifth story is gonna blow my
but this story is one of these crazy
Lifetime movie stories can't believe
it's true can't believe it's real it's
crazier than the adult child dwarf a
story of of weeks past yes it is I think
so at least and I haven't heard it
anywhere else so it's not like a toast
exclusive because it's from people calm
but we're about to blow this thing up
people always have has those stories
remember like back in the human interest
in a People magazine very immature at
the very end they always have a crazy
[ __ ] story yeah I once read to the
craziest one in 17 when I was younger
Aventine we used to live for that baby
used to write like the craziest [ __ ] in
the back that magazine that like sticks
with you and it's probably all false
yeah like tips and tricks what was I
crazy one that you're good oh it was you
know about a like a girl from Haiti who
was like living as a slave for her
family it was like hard sounds like that
ICU episode yeah
but anyways woman reunites with child
she thought died after birth 30 years
ago what it makes me want to cry Tina
Birgeneau said she was told her child
died minutes after she gave birth I
wasn't I really want to stop laughing
because it's like this is such a sad
sorry but you basically said vagina
you're like vagina vagina okay Johanna
Serrano
said Tina okay okay a mother has been
reconnected with her child almost three
decades after she was told the baby died
minutes following birth holy [ __ ] Tina
of Los Banos California welcomed a
daughter when she was 17 she explains to
keep mph but a day after the baby girl
was born Tina's mom delivered
devastating news about the child Kristin
the next day she comes back to tell me
that the baby died fifteen minutes after
it was born it never made it it was sick
for the next 29 years Tina and her
husband Eric would celebrate the baby's
birthday it was always a painful
experience no matter how much time had
passed
quote it was a hard time every year she
told kmph I would get depressed I would
cry all the time
oh my god she would go into major
depression added the husband
they got married shortly after the
baby's death and now they share five
children Wow but Tina would be in for
the surprise of a lifetime when her
daughter encouraged her to get a DNA kit
test in 2017 we got 23 minutes after
taking it Tina received an email from a
man living across the country in New
Jersey she told kmph quote I think we
need to talk it says we're related and
it says you're my mom the email read
recalled Tina who would soon learn of
the horrible truth what was Tina's back
on when she adopted or she just thought
like her parents were her parents um the
the child listen um it turns out that
Tina said that her mother had been
abusive and told her while she was
pregnant that she couldn't keep the baby
when she told her that baby died Kristin
when she told her that baby Kristin had
died after being born Tina's mother had
actually put her up for adoption
Wow Tina told me I mean I thought it was
a son no she thought she had a daughter
it turns out it was a son Oh oh my god
Tina said I don't care I don't care if
he's a UH oh oh I'm sorry
Kristin told Tina about being raised in
Las Vegas and transitioning into a man
oh okay okay now he is a man
she said Tina said I don't care I don't
care if he's in transition I don't care
if he has any transitioned I don't care
that's my kid we're just glad he's alive
what God what where's the mom that's the
mom still alive uh it's 30 years ago
holy [ __ ] the People magazine finds the
craziest [ __ ] stories this is
horrible I don't know who it's for worse
for I think it's worse for for Tina who
lived with 30 years of like depression
over over a lost child and I don't even
know and I hope to not going I'll never
know what that's like but it's such a
terrible thing or is it worse to have
never known who your parents are only
find them when you're 30 it's everyone's
a loser here like yeah yeah I think it's
it's I mean it's just comparing like
pain but I think it was definitely
harder for Tina who knew what she had
lost but it is for her son who probably
just thought he was adopted yeah and
probably had hopefully loving hell yeah
and didn't really know any better yeah
but is that not the craziest thing
you've ever heard insane that's insane
that's like reminds me of Jefferson
housewives when it turns out that
Juanita is not Gaby's daughter thinking
about the other day and when I rewatched
that episode I was like oh I forget how
they undid this because Juanita is
obviously Gabby starter she looks just
like Celia she looks just like Gabby and
she looks just like [ __ ] Carlos and
Carlos is mom
how did they undo it they did it it was
true she wasn't heard oh yeah but so I
mean that doesn't happen every day but
like do you switch back in that
situation was the question in in
Desperate Housewives they found the
parents of the other girl and Gaby fell
in love with grace who was really hurt
rude by Langille daughter but they were
undocumented and they ended up getting
deported oh yeah and that episode of
when Gaby calls a lot and she's crying
and that's where Gaby I really started
to hate her because she called the
immigration on the parents because she
wanted to keep the daughter here and she
and it ends up getting everyone in
trouble like so stupid that's when Gaby
like became at least favorite character
in television is oh my god I don't
remember this storyline I remember the
storyline but not how it ended that is
so awful and I hope that doesn't happen
like regularly I mean obviously it's a
dramatized series but it was really
[ __ ] crazy because stories protocol
do you switch back I don't know because
money that was their daughter for ten
years like how do you just stop loving
her even though you're not technically
related to her well then it becomes a
question of nature versus nurture right
three identity loss strangers yeah
always comes back everything always
comes back to everybody green me and
identical fingers 100% totally for sure
awesome right on that note let's go get
back in town yet we need to like take a
break because I need to talk to back I
didn't know she was coming right you had
questions for her let's put something on
our Instagram while I go pee yeah so I
don't turn this beautiful white couch a
little yellow maybe red and you know if
it's that time sorry we love you guys
we'll be right back with Becca and Tanya
from scrubbing in we are very excited we
will see you in a minute okay toasters
we are back with the scrubbing in ex TMT
collab and last time we collabed
it was kind of controversial and I'm
excited to just be out here I'm so glad
you're here we thought we were just
having time yeah because you were in why
I don't make this communication happen
well it happened because you said you
know to be honest when she texts me this
more she takes me this morning and she
goes are we doing the pot I was like
yeah where were you in the decks okay
I'm glad I wasn't the only one confused
I planned my whole I booked a super
early flight so I could be here Friday
we are so honored we are so so happy to
have you guys because you guys are a
dynamic duo ladies shoe podcast
scrubbing in we were just at the lady
gang before this they love you over
there and we are so excited because the
toasters love you you only love you we
love you
I'm a toasters which is and honored to
be I mean I have so much to talk to you
about but I need to talk to you first
and foremost about you talking about the
Jonah Hill thing on radio frying
seagrass Ryan Seacrest was like the
morning roast and you're like actually
it's the morning toast doing the Lord's
work it was such a point of pride for us
we really appreciate you brother I see
is that story though justice for Ruthie
never forgot it I'm never gonna get it
so the funny part is about that is that
like so I do these training reports for
the morning show and I'm always trying
to find things that like aren't you know
that are different and so like I'll try
and find stories and I'll try and get
like to do like my spin on the story or
like whatever you know like how I would
what what I would do if I was the star
whatever but when I listen to you I've
listened the morning toast every morning
and I heard you guys talk about this
Jonah Hill thing I was like I haven't
seen this on any like this is not on Us
Weekly is my way around yeah it's so
underground yeah I was like this is this
is premium content I was like I got to
bring it to the morning show give credit
where credit is that I can't believe
that Ryan's here I said the morning bro
well he said he doesn't want to roast
but I know he meant one letter away from
being on Ryan's best oh yeah we're okay
with that we are okay with that yeah it
was like really the story needed to be
heard no it's a three CS a Rooney could
have been this girl he's like in wedding
mode clearly um you just got back from
my Wyoming yes because you just launched
a clothing line with Macy's which is
like the craziest thing ever
it's very impressive thank you somehow
what is that like now you like what do
you call yourself because you're a host
you're an influencer now you're a
designer like we struggle with labels
here like I have now decided I'm a
comedian and Jackie's our host I'm host
yeah what do you guys call girl host
oh my gosh I struggle with this right
like if you're on a panel they would say
Becca Tilly , they actually say I think
the what is used as digital influencer
and podcaster oh that's good that's good
but now you're designer now I'm just a
you know fashion design medley but I got
to a point where I when strangers would
ask I would just be like I'm in
marketing I'm in sales I don't want any
follow-up questions yeah yeah you know
older people don't get it
and those conversations don't get easier
like it's so awkward but then there are
some things that you can say like you
could say podcaster and most people
would get that let me say like digital
content creators storyteller influencer
it gets a little dicey yeah so but
podcasting I think it's a great place to
me I'm glad that you guys like relate to
the struggle because it's something we
go through all the time yeah well you
also have the radio show you could
always say that and no one's gonna be
like what's the radio you're good you're
set for life sonyae I don't have any
sympathy or envy there's a drug like I
always get put like music experts I'm
like oh I'm into that I actually learned
like a lot of music from your Instagram
stories your ingenue stories are very
dynamic because I feel as though I'm
like motivated to work out but never
enough to like actually go
I learned me music and then I'm like
motivated to like change my life and be
a modern woman you know so there's big
dick energy and then there's modern
woman energy Wow that is that makes me
so happy because that's exactly and then
it's also like this [ __ ] is friends
with every celebrity like how do I do
that right that's it also the
aspirational facts yeah you just seem
like a great friend yeah and you're like
oh we support I got my friendships go
meet you and I'm like no wonder I have
no friends I'm never supporting anyone
cuz like you're always like city of
Carson UNICEF like you just did that
like you are all over all the collabs do
you like a schedule I think the thing
that I realize is that like especially
for women in this industry it's like if
we're not supporting each other and
we're not blasting each other as loud as
we can like are the men doing it right
no they know it's like I'm gonna do it
so hard for the people in my life that
matter to me and that's what we were
just hanging a lady in podcast because
they love you so much and it's like
technically scrubbing in morning toast
lady our competitors like right but yet
we're all here doing each other's
podcast I've done your guy's podcast
that's just not how we say everyone else
is the enemy not these people yeah yeah
and it's like people like Kelty and you
guys like you guys are so like
supportive it never like John Donne you
like not to do our podcast or vice versa
you know any yeah
and that that's a modern woman right
totally do you know what's so funny is I
just said the lady hanging with them and
Kelty was like I didn't want to like you
when I first met you because I just like
showed his carpet and like Charlie poops
kissing your cheek and I really like
loves you and I was like who's this girl
she's like and I met you and I really
liked you and
she was like how do you like sometimes
it's so hard because it is such a
competitive industry and like I'm an
inherently jealous person like of and I
think there's a little bit of that in
everybody I think like I think that when
you really think about it at the end of
the day like we're all so differently
even Beck and I like we could not be
more different it's like everybody has
something so unique to offer and it's
like you can't really like compare it
yeah like everybody literally has
something so different to offer and it's
like you're actually really surprised
not in like traditional Hollywood but
like in the space that we're in like for
the most part you meet everyone in
they're really nice yeah which is
shocking and like I was listening to the
marine toast I was I don't know a
problem in it a lot but that you want
your comedy special on Netflix
yeah totally if I like I know I friends
at work at Netflix and I'm like oh we
need to like this needs to happen la for
days and went to Dancing with the Stars
like we were being thirst to in the
background like clapping for everyone or
a Jackie thing like oh now we've been
having this conversation all day so cuz
you know how Christie Brinkley went and
then she got in trouble so CLO right on
so it's like maybe they were offered to
me and I would like to it for a week and
then like fake fall on my hand and then
be like oh no I can't believe me my
sister could do it Trek is an amazing
dancer my career goal to be a Dancing
with the Stars and I mean we know like a
tier of stardom right now to do it but
if I could ride my sister's coattails
all the way there I'm not too proud no
and then I would be there every day just
be like totally do dancing she's an
excellent dancer
yeah and I can learn some new moves I
hear the jatt the waltz have you ever
been offered either of you oh no because
a lot of people from The Bachelor
yeah it's normally a lead though oh is
it yeah I guess Joe grocery store Joe
true he had like he just blew out like
he had a great bachelor yeah like he's
grocery store job he could open up a
grocery store Joe he has a big career
ahead of him wait so do we need to get
on the dancing stars Jackie oh okay okay
one of my favorite campaigns Tanya Tebow
actually software I thought you
any rumors about like who you both cuz
you talk a lot about your dating life
for sure on the show are you talking
like you know code words yeah doctor we
know so whatever do you see doctor Venus
doctor Boise or something that was real
name right no I give them nicknames
because I just don't want yeah and like
this person doesn't choose to like my
profession is my profession and like
also the thing is I get really excited
when I date somebody it's not like a
producer sitting here being like you
knew when you gonna talk about your love
life it's like I just get excited I'm
like yeah excited to give him a like
nickname so that you know yeah that's
there but then do they listen to the
episode and like know that you're
talking about them and does that could I
interject here please so Tanya recently
dated a guy and she swore that he did
not listen because she asked him not to
she was like no he doesn't listen and
I'm like if I'm dating someone and they
have a podcast I know they talk about
their dating life I'd be like no it's a
cheat sheet of scrubs she like this she
didn't like that once more of it yeah
like I could almost be dumb for him not
to listen just to learn like good but he
told you an unfair advantage yeah like
does he actually like Laffy Taffy
certainly knows that you do some because
you said like you could get engaged in
married to this person it's like you
know nothing about them they're just
doing exactly what you they know you
want right and then it's like a hope
that relationship built on lies not to
scare you yeah either of you ever felt
you guys share so much on your podcast
and on the radio do you ever had a
moment where you felt like you over
shared I don't share a lot I'm like a
lot more private than Tanya I share a
lot but I don't talk a lot about my
dating life and so I could share about
anything and everything and people are
still like we want more Oh like that's
the one thing that you live by John and
that's the main thing that they want
yeah and they follow me from being in a
relationship on the track so I totally
get it at first I was like why why do
they need to know everything but I'm
like I get it yeah I just have to be
like you just go at my own pace yeah
yeah and what about you jus ever have
you ever felt like you over shared
[Laughter]
literally like I the sad thing is and so
okay so I wasn't like a really bad
breakup and I did it I didn't do it on
the air because when I was with
and um it was just like really sad and I
like went through it like hardcore so
it's kind of been like like my dating
life has been just kind of like a part
of the show of the show and sometimes it
doesn't it really the only thing that
sucks is when it ends like with a guy
and then everybody is like oh like
obviously she's so annoying
I would dump her too and I think they
don't know like exactly what happened
because when things and like I try to be
respectful in to say like yeah I'm not
dating anymore or whatever I'd only go
into details like if you only knew half
of the stuff that way right not annoying
idea Thank You line to walk because you
don't want to like make yourself look
bad but you also don't want to air
someone's dirty laundry who's not
totally but also I'm like this is what
dating is it's like yeah and something
and then it's like I gotta get back up
and get on the horse like all of this is
foreign to us cuz like we're married and
we've never had to know what it's like
Tyco share updates on your dating life
and I'm Sheriff [ __ ] sucks yeah II
think is hard enough it doesn't suck
because it's so exciting so it's like oh
my god I come in and I'm like is your
career a Ford you exciting dating
opportunity right like Juman could zoom
in and ask to Ryan and be like I know
you're friends with someone so within
the [ __ ] so with the wind Zachary I
have like a really crush on Zachary Levi
and he came on the morning show do you
remember that and like it was actually
really funny like Ryan tried to kind of
like make something happen but without
really make it like near to me like not
like a casual very casual and I was
actually pretty do that would snitch all
the time all the time yeah yeah I didn't
snitch Schwartzman yeah okay so what
happened when he likes fake set you up
um like well we had already talked so we
were two knew each other and we kind of
had like a good thing like kind of but
we never really actually gone went out
ever cuz he was like in and out he was
promoting the movie and was like in the
now of the city have you ever dated
anyone famous cuz you're like you are
always meeting famous people like you
just had a picture with normani on your
Instagram like like you're always yeah
it's like her I see yeah and you don't
think it's crazy but like it is it is
kind of crazy
yeah um however did date anybody famous
like even just like a coffee date yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah whoo they have
nicknames
say can you tell us the CD or movie No
TV movie or influencers will guess yeah
some of them you probably would not know
a guy made out with mmm you remember
there's like three give us the realm
they was a CW on a CW show ever no no
and then one of them is from a reality
show which one no oh yeah well there
better be there better be yeah no Bravo
no this is the past you know all of
these survivor kind of I know CW that
one you might not know he's married now
so it's like coming Oh actually I
appreciate that junk yeah I agree
yeah how did you guys meet I want to ask
that question to a pool party we met at
the I heart Vegas Boulevard E Oh in May
we just realized it was May and not so
happy she remembers our friend because
we had a best friends close and I got
that wrong so now it's like seared in my
memory it was May and then she moved
into my apartment complex and we shared
a wall for like a year
oh yeah that is it is it's the best
thing ever I don't like keep her door
unlocked every time I came home from
work I would like come in and be like
that's like a roommate but you know I'm
sure like have a roommate mm-hmm we
don't to be alone yeah
that sense of fun it was the best and
you guys have been podcasting now for
how long - over two years yeah and we
guys wanted People's Choice Award yes
nominate again this year but you're nice
must be nice we're happy for you I'm
gonna bring it up I glad you did thank
you for reminding me Jackie you're
welcome
so let's talk about that who did you
have to pay that's the first year like
literally last year when they told us we
were nominated we both were like are we
being Punk'd is like a mean joke you're
like a mean joke once I looked at the
list and it was like Oprah doing
something mean honestly I thought for
sure lady Inge was gonna win because
they had just gotten a show on a so it's
like you guys really won based on your
merits in your votes which is really
cool it's so cool and honestly like we
campaigned really hard last year like we
went hard for the votes I have like my
family like everybody in Serbia voting
every
twenty-five times a day I have my
uncle's like a professor in Serbia had
it like all the students in this class
were voting every day yeah cool yeah
what's your last name
Ronny sabbia beach cleaner
professionally yeah brain question yeah
never occurred to me that might not be
your real name okay one more time ruddy
sabbia Beach that's so cool respect if
she can spell it it's okay and I don't
know J I be wrong Booker flights and I'm
like I just one more time
send me the name she keep it in your
notes oh my god that's so funny
okay we got tons of questions of you
guys for you guys from social media for
both of you specifically so without
further ado I'm just gonna rattle them
off and feel free to answer to your best
ability okay Wow oh yeah cuz I need to
find when there's so many comments yay
are you still working with Teddy
Mellencamp and holding yourself
accountable oh that's a great question
did you all in I did online is so good
thank you I appreciate that I I did it
for about a year I'm not on it anymore
but it works yeah I heard you gives you
like five calories I'm saying that's
what I heard it's not great it's not a
food but like it's so weird and although
that's kind of where I started posting
like after I work out like I post my
stories and stuff like that because it's
kind of weird when you feel like feel
like you're in a community of people
that's like in a healthy together yeah
it's like being a part of the podcast
honestly hold like you're all losing
weight together instead of listening to
the same show totally yeah yeah like
Andi Dorfman has done that with the
endorphins thing she has like the whole
running community oh yeah she's running
a Taylor say hello
potato say oh my god yes oh yes he's
like too pretty I think this is for both
of you guys you guys have had ton of gas
you just celebrated your hundredth
episode right you got tons of gas who is
the one that like star struck you the
most you
[Laughter]
sex Minds second most second most
Camilla Luddington I was Anatomy right
Oh guys we don't watch Grey's Anatomy
but we respect you we respect your stand
but like I've never even seen an episode
like I don't even know what McDreamy
means it's something Donald yeah I'm the
dollar funny like we know nothing about
it and like I think she's gonna come way
too far behind I'm sure I would like it
but actually a great show to like binge
watch great from the biggest still on is
it considered like a soap opera at this
point at this place just on for so long
like a dramedy yeah we used to watch
Desperate Housewives growing up and like
it was always on right after it's like
Emily that should have still on ya like
imagine I mean we would have a podcast
called do either of you guys have any
advice for someone moving to LA how not
to get sucked up in at all in stay true
to yourselves
cuz you both like go to a lot of cool
things meet a lot of cool people but
you're very normal both you yeah cause
it's like easy to get carried away like
we got paparazzi last night and honestly
we're I mean live here like you've been
paparazzi many a time you're not always
on the red carpet but that's true like
how do you deal with it seriously and
like not and not like really become an
[ __ ] I've only gotten paparazzi when
I'm with somebody like it's never for me
excuse me I saw a video of you on TMZ
through a fence talking about Ryan
Seacrest okay and they were like yelling
for me I was like from the Star Tours
right yeah so any advice get plugged
into a community I was just gonna say
like moving here having a group of
friends already was very important
that's like outside of the you know
entertainment world yeah we talked about
ours but for a moment I love nothing
more so we've been sitting on this yeah
so you did you interview her at Ryan
Seacrest when she was promoting me
yes and
she merch yes she came over so sorry
Jacky's are you like an outspoken look
that you've been on kim kardashian's
instrum sorry team Kim and Taylor knew
that can you talk to me about that
experience like just like why is it
funny I'm dead serious like interviewing
Taylor yeah you will like literally lose
your mind when I tell you we did like
when she was premier when she was
releasing 1989 and she was like doing
that whole campaign back then she filled
in for a full morning it was like the
Taylor Swift takeover but she had to do
it in New York City so they sent over
like two producers and I got to be one
of them so I was like literally in a
small studio like this producing Taylor
for the morning and was she like bunny
cares like what does she like just
everything my god it was everything yeah
you go to the reputation stadium tour
obviously obviously what you go to the
rep room
no I'm searching for an invitation and
it turns out that the day that she did
three shows in New York and I went to
the third one and she didn't do a rep
room that night well that's why I didn't
go no I mean it's also like even if
there was I probably wouldn't have
gotten one but now that I've been
recognized with the merch like maybe
I'll get to the lovers lounge for sure
but like I can't believe that you have
to go to the rep room do you have a
picture with her yeah I hate like so
much this is my jealousy like I came the
rules of the rehab good question there
wasn't any rule sue do you post your
picture with her yeah but they take the
picture for you take the picture for you
so you'll get it yeah I would do that
too if I was I wouldn't totally do that
too we got a lot of questions if you
guys would ever do a podcast tour for
scrubbing in because people love you
guys just did a mean green right at
Nordstrom I was just re meeseeks you
ever take it off take it on the road we
would love to yeah
in a perfect world we would totally do
it we're working on it it's just there's
um like different there since you know
we're with a big company there are rules
and regulations so yeah it was your
dream podcast guest I actually want to
do a hot we've been talking about this
like on different podcasts like a
podcast merge with like oh like a bunch
of podcast yeah like um ice lady game
yeah fix an office like girls like
that's cute yeah
we were talking on the lady getting
podcast a about hosting a podcast award
show since the one award show that gives
out podcast Awards refuses to
acknowledge our existence and like maybe
would you like the toasties and like
we'd give out like hosts of the year you
know obviously go to us but cast hosted
by a Bachelorette who was dating trouble
with is now dating she's Turek you know
I don't know who we could go to I don't
know it's interesting if you think about
yeah yeah yeah we just think how much we
appreciate the wonderful sunset
happening behind us I know this is like
so la like has they have it over New
York the lighting here like obviously
you guys get blamed and yeah left and
right a question yeah cuz I just came
from Wyoming and I throw a New York
enjoyed the fall weather yeah and I got
back here and I was mad at how hot it
was you're missing out on the seasons
here like it's really okay so you do
feel like you do get a bit of seasons in
one day here like in the morning it is
chilly to the valley oh my god you're
dying on crete lot like we were dying
yeah and the winding roads to get there
I thought maybe the city isn't for me
maybe I won't move yeah about like the
the windy roads are really like [ __ ]
Canyon Coldwater Canyon it's all I never
thought I would have something in Civ
alley like I am the valley you hear
valley girls everyone always tells us
the windy roads she really gets very
seasick like she was gonna throw up in
the car yeah
wait so I don't know I have a question
not who I thought I was because you
obviously started your journey here on
The Bachelor but like you've really
evolved past it like I actually forgot
you that you were on The Bachelor
which is a great thing I mean that in a
huge compliment but there's so much like
Bachelor tea and drama that like you're
on volume but I would love to get your
take on um because Colton like recently
came out swinging I'm Rachael Lindsay
which I was personally not here forcus
like I really like rich Lindsay saying
like she's starting fights with everyone
and her and her and Raven aren't friends
anymore and I know you know all these
people and you probably have more
insider info than anyone else like what
side do you take where do you send I
don't have much I'm I don't know that I
don't know any of those people you just
mentioned that well
oh I don't know them I'm like oh I get
why she's Mariah Carey I don't know her
I suddenly can't read like I'm I'm
literally that person that's so curious
about what's going on with know like I
have no idea but you know I I feel like
because I including myself you do not
yeah but we would never say oh yeah you
could tell us anything by the way and
yeah we're we are really good friends
like trap door that's what we always say
it's like when we watch Real Housewives
or like Kardashians and it always like
what Jordan did to Kylie was so terrible
because they were such close friends and
like the Kardashians really value
loyalty it's like we're there for you
Kylie like we are really good friends
like and like even breathe if you guys
want to like become best friends like we
will be really keep your secrets like
we're not - dang it makes the friendship
bar really high
yeah is it is it like I mean I'm like so
just like I don't do you ever get like
I'm like this and I only ask because
this is what I do do ever get like
jealous like that she has so many
friends you know it's like I have
friends and like you're not allowed to
have other friends OC no I don't because
I couldn't handle that likes a lot of
friends Mason worked together
I like she's such a great friend except
I noticed she brought y'all like
Halloween candy back and she did it for
all of her neighbors and she didn't even
know maybe this she didn't know you were
coming today multiple time she's gonna
see you on Halloween
bigger better Rebecca would you ever be
the Bachelorette like over say no but
like it's one of those things would be
like I'd write your life yes if you're
not dating anyone like you would think
about it oh yeah I mean if I was saying
if the money's good enough yeah it's not
money right it's it true that to match
your annual salary
oh well no cause now it's harder because
everyone like becomes so influential
they're making way more money
ah but it's like if you were a sales rep
they would just have to cover about your
sales reps um they do like my job before
what was your job before I was a
chiropractic assistant if they haven't
matched my money and make nothing do you
know how to line it back no I was just I
was a chiropractic assistant I basically
made the appointment and brought so I
won't ask you to adjust me that someone
on The Bachelor but when we were filming
I was like would you mind addressing me
and I was like no I don't need a lawsuit
on my hand talk about the processes for
Marissa flack of getting started on your
own like label like how do you just like
start a label like and become a designer
where do you get the like the paper draw
you know like what you know what I mean
yes so I so they the toast merch yes
next level yeah me restock coming soon
hey did it just sell out yes I know I
meant to get you a free sweatshirt but
they gone I'll get you such a bag is the
fact that I bought from when it went on
sale and like when other posters like
need a flag like I shipped that my flag
it's The Sisterhood of the Traveling
just at someone's wedding weddings why
it's going to a wedding in Mexico in
December like it's that's how that's how
we work right Connie loves The
Sisterhood of the Traveling something do
you what do you try to use scissors say
it again
hope for this for there you just talks
about money journals so he said I've
started many journals for the Scarlet
sisters that's cool
so you writing it we all write in it and
then I haven't ship it off but it's so
cute I love that idea
it's so nice what does your shirt say to
rad to be sad oh my god that's my just
made it oh yeah well for your own
mercilessly Jack Vanek yeah man help me
help me maybe she like has a thing with
t-shirts right that's cool yeah wait I
didn't answer my clothes they reached
out to me I worked with a production
team so they were the ones who like
design I just got to say like what I
wanted right so I love this letter what
can we do it this way I love this
American we do it this way how long was
the whole process from start to finish I
started in January and it was just
released last week so almost a year it's
like a baby it's like nine months
exactly that's so exciting and it's huge
congratulations when stuff is so cute
and the pictures are so cute
Tommy has been my best quarter biggest
supporter I love you it's so major that
you learn your name and your label in
Macy's it's like you look sad
I know that's cool isn't it like the
little things that like make it really
special I gave a clothing but the cool
part is the tag you know yeah that got
me really excited just let us know if
we're keeping you too long cuz we got so
many questions for you guys I just want
to keep this is actually a really
interesting question from Jackie surname
what are you just over like people like
thinking about you like are there any
misconceptions about you like people say
so many mean things about us and it's so
not true and like you guys we don't have
like as much [ __ ] to deal with us we do
but like what are you just over what are
y'all over I'm curious over people
messaging me about them I'm like right
so I went on their path for seems really
these evil like KKK members it's
actually so good I don't know literally
like so I went for those who don't know
I my god can either way which was so
nice I didn't even know you back then
and I was like Tim's girl so nice she
really is a good friend they went on
your podcast we had such a good time
Janel Parrish was there like I thought I
thought we were hilarious the moral
compass thing remember we had such good
stick and then like I was in trouble I'm
like what did I do and your viewers were
very upset that you guys had me on your
show almost like I'm like David Duke or
something you know like you don't I mean
yeah no I know and so I really
appreciate a you guys having me and then
be going about for me well cuz it's like
everybody makes mistakes we all make
mistakes and we all say and do things
that like we've regretted and like I
just don't believe that your your past
you know nobody in like it's just so and
then though you can't grow totally it's
just like who are we like you know cast
the first stone know who the hue who has
not sinned by quoting verses no I'm so
tired of the canceled culture because
it's it's fine if you like if it's
current but from something that's so far
in your past to me is just it's not fair
like no one gives grace no we no one can
show they need it there's like that's
such a good point and there's like so
much value in like growth and like
learning from your mistakes like no
one's allowed to and it's like you said
something ten years ago that's who you
are now
yeah why do you want that to be Who I am
now we can do our show every single day
and make people smile make people happy
and people just want to think that we
are these evil people but it's like why
do you want that to be these people in
the world who are influencing other
people yeah why not look and see the
good that we do yeah why doesn't make
you high also think that's part of the
charm of this this podcast it's like you
guys actually keep it real and we talk
and they get a lot of people go through
like huge public things and then never
want to talk about it cuz like it's
embarrassing and that actually is really
hard to talk about there's not a day
that goes by where we don't talk about
it like because it
the less you talk about it the more
other people talk about it but if I'm
bringing it up all the time like there's
no way for anyone to like you know shame
me for that yeah and now it's just like
so part of the whole sure and like
because we've been through it like we
feel it's important to speak on it
because it's just had its the the amount
that it's happening now like even that
guy who was just trying to do charity
with the the beer company was just
looking for it like she was donating
money to the Iowa The Children's
Hospital Oh a reporter found his old
tweets from like so so long ago right
and that should not be happening so yeah
they're here to say stop it um Becca
would you where are you gonna be a
Bachelorette for Jojo um you mean a
bridesmaid Oh Oliver we're going all of
her bridesmaids bachelorettes yes
she hasn't officially asked me but she
told I think like Us Weekly or something
that she was gonna ask me but I heard
from them that's hilarious I'm waiting
to get like my you know like stuff
delivery was growing yeah but yeah
that's so exciting probably say yes
decided aside from obviously because I'm
with Macy's where do you guys shop for
clothes because you guys have to like go
to events and stuff like you're moving
stuff you're looking at her really yeah
she no she she really gives me way too
much credit she buys really cute clothes
and she'll send me photos and be like
which one do you like and he thinks that
that's me styling her and I'm like no
you put that I tell everybody I'm like
Becca Styles me it's not true
we stylist it's like I appreciate the
credit but it's not fair because you're
doing more than you give yourself credit
for
so I I have worked with stylists before
and I have I also shop yeah it's fun
Zara you know it yeah I think that the
first world problem that I have is that
you post photos or you get photographed
in it and then you're like oh we do a
show every day because we film our
podcast it's like so I don't got to get
all my my clothes from like forever 21
yeah yeah yeah I'm over that though I
know if Megan markle's doing an open way
yeah
outfit repeater yeah yeah thing to theme
I mean I have five shirts I have to be I
wear the same workout clothes to work I
have
good morning I literally looks like a
pile of poop every how do you wake up so
early and do like you've now been up for
24 12 hours yeah I really honestly like
I thrive in the morning like I'm at my
peak Tania at like 6:00 a.m. that is so
it's weird because I like wake up and I
like and I do mind like my job and I'm
like that's what I'm like my best yeah
like right now is when I feel like I'm
like it's so funny because we normally
do our podcast at around like 11:00 in
the morning and I come in and I'm like
tired from it yeah 15 coffee yeah like
on one and then we did a podcast from
Vegas at the I heart festival and we did
it late it was like 9 p.m. at 9:00 not
late but it was like in the night time
and I was like I was like maybe we do
like one nighttime podcast every month
just know I have one final question for
you guys and it's a little shady I'm
sorry because you guys went on a trip
and you did a live podcast from it was
like a vineyard or something my
Temptation Island I don't know but you
did it with Jana Kramer oh that was just
Tonya and now that just yeah ok then I
need to ask you because they were just
in the news recently and they're their
names came across our desk for like them
fighting on their podcast about him
finding naked pictures or whatever like
what were they like in person were they
fighting um were they fighting yeah I
think no but that was just that was
episode where she said she walked down
and said all talking on our podcast oh
god yeah she basically walked out I was
sitting at dinner like we were all kind
of like just everybody just eats at this
like place cuz there was a bunch of POD
we were all doing our show or whatever
and so we were sitting on a table just
to it was talking cuz I don't know like
husband yes and she walked in and saw us
there and like I guess it triggered her
and she brought it up on the podcast I'm
sure I know and she started crying I
felt really bad because I'm like I know
that's hard lately I'm also like the
most harmless like a harmless like you
could put me in a room with like 100
married men and I would not do with damn
things you know show GCB no good
Christian [ __ ] no you're just you get
your one slide on abc's in wonder
it's coming back yeah I'm not in the leg
way like someone got the rights again
and they're gonna do it again but the
original Kristin Chenoweth Leslie baby
is iconic yeah Wow yeah and your buddy's
like we're nice she was girls in your
GCV yeah I think he's good Christian
[ __ ] but I thought I felt really bad
for her because I'm like that is bad
yeah I actually listened to that podcast
on the way from the airport was it
shocking like hearing your name being
brought up on another podcast is that
well for us it's like worst [ __ ]
feeling like heart yeah what the [ __ ]
did they say about me now
you guys say my name on this podcast I
feel like I'm like hearing like the
White House call my neighbors like when
we know people listen to the show like
we knew certain new we know like certain
influencers and celebrities listen like
I'm always dropping their names just
like they'll text me or something you
know I'm just like craving attention
like did you know did you know that they
said your name on the morning toes great
like you have to listen to the choice
cuz the toaster will tell you it so it's
like if you guys ever bring up my name
it's like a scrubbing in person will DME
like hey 18 minutes and 30 seconds is
there anything meaning cover before we
let you guys go because it's officially
dark out this episode has started and
now it's dark outside it's like a
time-lapse at the time of the crazy
anything I need to talk about
unfortunately like we should let you go
but anything else where can people get
the Macy's collab so it's in over 400
Macy's stores I think you can find
online which locations it's at or call
your local Macy's and then also
available online what do you say pieces
are yeah every the whole collections
online so everyone can shop there and
when you guys drop scrubbing in episodes
normally Mondays every Monday everybody
can vote yeah yeah yeah you can't vote
for us on Friday so this will be out
tomorrow 25 times a day you can make a
million different accounts scrubbing in
you guys like each get a plus-one cuz I
oh yeah actually don't know for going
yeah we haven't got imagine imagine
being having the honor bestowed upon you
and not even showing up imagine last
year you guys were there and they didn't
announce it at the show yeah I think
they did you know they weren't going to
get such a great story so we go not
expecting to be shown or I mean
presenting like Mila Kunis you know
we're like they're probably not gonna do
pop podcast but maybe they'll do it on a
screen during a commercial break we
thought like yeah maybe before on the
red carpet you know we just thought
somewhere they'd sneak it in so the
whole time we're at the podcast table
and before we sit down we go to the
restroom and Donnie runs into a girl
from e way yeah what'd she say she told
she goes do you have your speeches ready
oh so during this time there are a bunch
of fires going on and it was like during
the Malibu fires and so we are sitting
at the table and we're like should we
bring up the fires in our suite we're
literally the whole we're nervous we're
let you know you had one already so we
got an email because we got invited yeah
and it kind of alluded to the fact that
we had one in that category but it was
nothing it didn't feel like an official
thing I want to Jillian I was scared to
even get excited I was just like we'll
know for sure after the window the whole
show goes by now still no confirmation
no announcement no speech needed we were
watching - you were like maybe there's a
write-in candidate who won the most
getting into our uber like it's over
like yeah heading into the Bur Kelty
calls me and she's like congratulations
see you found out from kelsey that is so
funny
and did you get a physical award yes one
or two house one one yeah it was
supposed to be like on and off message
on it yet you're still off okay we just
had to get you another it's epic on that
is our campaign that is our campaign you
could also listen to Tanya how much this
week you're on radio I've is a week
Monday through Friday kiss FM his of him
in the morning set is so cool thanks
feel free to mention this experience
tomorrow until yeah we're gonna have a
libido and then disco this weekend your
show your comedy shows gonna get a
special app for them and then running it
you know dancing with stars yeah and
honestly we've just really now like
start to understand like the whole
concept of like ass believe receive that
you can't get something if you never
physically say it so is anything you
guys want to say that you want
you have a clap now with Maci so I don't
really need anything yeah yeah what
about you anything you wanna say it
um I am actually preparing myself for
the man of my dreams oh my god I love
you so much I'm preparing it for you too
I'm starting my 10-day journal tomorrow
and then I have a seven week workshop
that I start on Monday Wow
yeah I'm like really like serious yeah
I'm happy it's gonna happen for you I
feel it I do I do it it's it's like
actually good questions like it's a it's
a at home workshop it's a book it's
called calling in the one have you heard
of it because you don't go anywhere nice
dude like everything yeah you do one
thing that's like it's a seven-week
program yeah I know I've tried to end
the podcast three times now so let's try
one more time thank you guys so much for
being here we absolutely love you this
was such a fun episode make sure to
check out scrubbing in follow Becca and
Tommy on Instagram check out Becca's
Club you guys have so many things to
push I love it Oh check out Tanya on the
radio all the things vote for them in
the People's Choice Awards if you can't
be US it should be them and we will be
back tomorrow Thursday with an episode
with your favorite Morgan Stewart so we
will see you then bye
[Music]